hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in letter number nine senica is
going to weigh in with his thoughts
about a very important topic one that
was you could say say often discussed in
ancient times and if we're going to
think about the present we've got our
own discussions about this but there's
many people who want to go back to
ancient philosophy and bring it forward
and live it out in the present and I
think that this problem this question
arises for them then as well and it has
to do with this person that may or may
not exist called the save or the wise
person the sapiens the person who really
knows and for the stoics and really for
all of the ancient schools of philosophy
it it's not merely having a lot of stuff
packed in your head it's the person
who's actually acquired wisdom and
understands what's good or bad for human
beings and can actually live that out in
their life and they bring up somebody
who could be an example of this in Stilo
who was was a great philosopher of the
mearan school and was influential on the
stoics through Zeno right the founder of
stoicism senic is going to begin by
saying and he's talking to his his
epicurian leaning friend
lilus you eager to know whether epicurus
was justified in the criticism expressed
in one of his letters against those who
say that the wise person is
self-sufficient now the term that
they're using there is suff
Su right is the infinitive so it's not
an adjective there're self-sufficient
it's rather that they suffice onto
themselves and because of this according
to these these people the the wise
person would have no need of a friend
and so senica says okay we have to look
at different conceptions of what it
means to be a wise or fully developed
human person says it's a charge made
against him epicurus against Stilo and
others who say that the highest good is
an impassible mind and here senica says
okay we got to be a little bit careful
with our
vocabulary so in Greek we have this this
conception of apatha right which could
be understood as not having any path
passions or emotions or it could also be
understood in terms of only having good
emotions but not the bad ones or not
being shaken by things and he says how
should we render this in Latin and he
says that um if we want to translate it
with a single term and say
impaciencia we're getting in a little
bit of trouble ambiguity why because
impaciencia can be understood in the
opposite sense to what we intend we mean
by it a person who refuses to feel any
Misfortune but it will be taken to refer
to one who cannot bear any Misfortune
when we talk about somebody being
impatient in our own present day English
that's coming from impaciencia somebody
who can't suffer things and we often
talk about it in terms of time but in
you know Latin in ancient and medieval
and even early modern times it was
understood as one who will not bear with
things so like if you can't take
somebody saying bad stuff about you and
you get angry you can't patiently deal
with that right you can't suffer it we
might say so senica is going to say
here's the way in which we stoics uh are
going to look at it after he says maybe
we should talk about the invulnerable
mind the mind that can't be wounded or
the Mind Set beyond all suffering and he
says our position is different from
theirs people like Stilo in that our
wise person conquers all
adversities uh in commodum and in
commoda is a term that is actually used
quite a lot in uh ancient and medieval
Latin to talk about you know the things
that they're not good in themselves but
they're kind of nice to have and so the
opposite of that incomoda you know so
your tie actually ties well matches your
shirt doesn't uh you know chafe you or
something like that well that's a
commodum and the opposite of that your
tie doesn't feel good well that's an
incom modm right so it's not like all
adversity but it's you know a wide range
of those sorts of things and so he says
that they still feel the in
commoda um theirs does not even feel
them they're they're beyond that and so
he says we have a common ground in
saying that the sage is self-sufficient
and actually the translations here in
English can be a little bit misleading
because what he says their common ground
is is being content the wise person is
content with themselves say IPO right uh
with their very own person but he does
say that they both have a as well that
the um Sage is self-sufficient right
suffices on to themselves but here's
where the difference lies for
senica even though the sage is content
with himself he still
wishes uh to have some sort of friend
right and the term there that we're
going to see arising over and over again
V wishes or you could say Wills chooses
to have friends and then the question
would be well why would he if he's
totally
self-sufficient and so he talks about
this analogy says to see how
self-sufficient he is consider this
there are times when he's satisfied with
just part of himself if his hand were
cut off in battle if an accident cost
him an eye the remaining parts of
himself would be sufficient with him for
him he would be as hand with his body
diminished as he was with it with it
whole although he does not feel the want
the the loss of the missing limbs he
would prefer that they not be missing
and so when we apply this to friends he
says he's self-sufficient not in that he
wants to be without a friend but that
he's able to be without a friend so when
his friend dies he can bear the loss
with equinity and then he also says
something very interesting here
he won't be without a friend for long
why because wise people are naturally
good candidates for friendship right and
he says just as this sculptor fidas if
he should lose one of his statues would
immediately make another one um so this
artist at friend making will substitute
another in place of the one who's lost
and then there's a little bit of a
digression here how is he going to make
a friend so quickly and you know he says
that you know it's Pleasant to make
friends and if we think about how the
wise person is they are the sort of
person who can make friends quite easily
with the right sort of people they're
not going to be
indiscriminately uh you know confiding
in everybody opening up their heart to
everybody but they're ready to do so you
could say and senica doesn't say this
here but we could easily think there's
less obstacles for them less baggage to
get in the
way now this then raises some
interesting problems and questions and
sonaka says um okay this is fair we
really do need to talk about this he
says even if the sage is self-sufficient
he still wants to have a friend and we
can say all right why if he's
self-sufficient what does he need a
friend for and the answer is he doesn't
need a friend we're going to make an
important distinction here
but he will choose he will will to have
a friend why well one of the biggest
reasons is such a great virtue
Magna we don't want that not to be used
to go fallow we could say to go uh
unused Yak which literally means to like
throw down right uh putting something
away right uh that you don't actually
need
so again the wise person doesn't need
friends but they will choose friends so
that they can exhibit their wisdom and
virtue in relation to those friends
benefiting them and he gives some
examples of this so you know epicurus
might say to have somebody sit beside
him in illness or assist him in
imprisonment or in need and senaka says
no it's the other way around the wise
person needs to have somebody who he
himself May sit beside side in illness
who he may liberate from an enemy's
capture right to do good things to the
other person it's to take one's goodness
and put it out there in the world into
other people and their
lives epicurus as we just saw you know
the goal is to get your friends so that
they will help you when you are in need
right um and you know they'll they'll
get you out of binds and stuff like this
and epicurus does actually say that so
he says that we should really think
about this if we have friends solely on
the basis of utility or expediency
utilitas in Latin usefulness right then
that's as far as it's going to go and
we're going to have a real problem with
what he calls fa WEA friends or in Latin
temporis friends only of a certain age
and he says you know this is what you
actually see people have all sorts of
friends hanging around when they're
doing good and then when they have the
opportunity to prove their friendship
then these friends run away that's why
there's terrible stories of people
abandoning their friends or betraying
them and he says listen beginnings and
endings must agree so if your if your
friendship begins with expediency that's
where it's going to end and he actually
has a great quip here this is actually
less than a friendship and more of a
business deal a negoto right you make
some sort of agreement now epicurus
seems to have thought that that's where
it starts and you can get out of that
Sonica is saying boy if that's the basis
of your friendship you're never going to
get past that then he goes on to talking
about um lovers you know people who are
involved in relationships of Attraction
of what we could call romantic or erotic
love right they're like friends but in
in a certain way they're not truly
friends in this way he says that you
could say that love is a friendship but
then he adds go on mad so it's not the
kind of friendship that we're looking at
here but he uses it to make a really
interesting argument so he says does
anyone fall in love in order to make a
profet and you know you could say well
people have sex with each other to make
a profit or they use people well they're
not in love then right so no uh the
desire that goes with that in erotic
attraction if infatuation whatever you
want to call it is on a different level
than mere
expediency and so senica then says um
for the sake of ambition Glory love all
by itself caring nothing for other
objectives inflames the mind with desire
for the others Beauty and hopes the
affection will be returned what shall we
conclude does a base emotion arise from
a more honorable origin and the
implication here is you got you know
utility business deals lover
relationships and then you have actual
real friendships in the Fuller sense um
each one has its own range to it and one
is better than the other so now he's
going to go on and he says okay you say
our question is not whether friendship
is Choice worthy in itself and he says
no no that is something that we need to
ask uh that's the point that needs to be
established because if friendship is
choiceworthy worthy of pursuing for its
own sake then it is possible for one who
is self-sufficient to Pur it and how
does that work how can the person who's
actually got it
all how can they be motivated to choose
to pursue friendship and so he says all
right I'm going to give you some
arguments about this so the first one um
he's going to say is uh like any very
beautiful thing REM pul
so any Beautiful Affair any beautiful
matter you're drawn to it for its own
sake I mean you've experienced this with
other things why not with friendship
that's only one of the arguments that
he's going to give them so then he says
um we can make a
distinction as to the person who is
self-sufficient when it comes to living
a good life B
now notice that the good here the beate
isn't Ben which is well it's beate
happily right or blissfully so it's
there's Living Well we could say and
then there's actually enjoying happiness
in the life that you're living versus
just living in general
vendum and this is a distinction that
you know gets made quite a lot in
ancient philosophy so Sen isn't
originating this you can actually see it
in Aristotle's politics and nicam mccan
ethics when he talks about living well
and just living and ties it in with our
social nature which is going to come up
in just a
bit so if we make this distinction we
can say that the wise person doesn't
need things as far as living happily but
they may need things with respect to
just plain old living right he says um
there's a lot of things that they
require but to live happily only a sound
and upright mind that arises Superior to
Fortune then he brings up CPUs a very
important early stoic writer often times
called the second founder of stoicism
and CPUs is going to make a distinction
between lacking or being in need of
a and having use for something Opus
essay something being of use or II using
something and he says that uh the wise
person doesn't lack anything but they
have a use for many things and here's
his quote by contrast there's nothing
the foolish person has a use for because
they don't know how to use things and
yet they lack everything the wise person
has a use for hands and eyes and many
other things that are needed for
everyday living yet lacks nothing so uh
even though he's self-sufficient he has
a use for our friends and wants to have
as many of them as possible he doesn't
want them in order to have a good life
because he's going to have a good life
with friends or without but he certainly
can use them right and you know we get
this very interesting discussion what
what sort of life will the wise man have
if they're left without friends when in
captivity stranded in some foreign
country delayed on some long Voyage Cast
Away on a desert island senica actually
experienced Exile himself so he says
well and this is something that we see
epicus talking about in a chapter on
friendship later on as well the kind of
life that Zeus or Jupiter has this goes
to a stoic idea when the universe like
comes apart into its elements and gets
put together back again this is the only
being still left in the universe but
he's fine because he's got all that he
needs within himself he devotes himself
to his own thoughts and rests in himself
and he says that the sage can uh do
something like that he Retreats into
himself and is his own company right but
if they have the option of having things
in their life he talks about having a
spouse uh raising children both
self-sufficient right and he says here's
the next thing what brings the the
person whatever person we're talking
about to Friendship is as he's going to
say um a sort of Natural Instinct and he
says just as we innately find certain
other things appealing so it is with
friendship it is inherent in us to shun
Solitude and seek companionship just as
nature attaches
human beings to each other there's an
innate prompting a stimulus to pursue
friendships now a little bit of
vocabulary here so the term that Sonica
is talking about as in terms of
attaching
consat this is the verb for a noun that
is in Latin stoic text used to translate
the Greek
osis which if you know anything about
stoicism you know is this sort of
affiliation or belonging and and it can
be worked with it's something that that
naturally arises say between parents and
children or you know people that are
banded together in some way but it can
be expanded to the entire universe and
so senica is saying yeah we've got this
natural urge within us which then we can
work with and so does the wise person
because they're a human being
right now he he finishes up by talking
about the example of the person we
started with Stilo so Stilo uh his
homeland fell to Invaders his children
were lost his wife was lost he alone
survived the destruction of his people
he emerged happy and when Demetrius uh
asked him whether he'd lost anything he
said all my goods are within me and
Senus says here's a brave person and a
tough one he conquered even his enemy
Conquest all my goods are within me
Justice courage prudence and this in
itself the ability to think that nothing
is good which can be taken
away and uh he says SOS saying is shared
by the stoic he also carries his Goods
within himself through the devastation
of City he's self-sufficient and it's by
this limit he defines his Prosperity but
that doesn't mean that you're not going
to look for friends when you can
actually have them your happiness is not
dependent upon having friends but
there's no reason why you wouldn't seek
them out as a stoic and so this is
senica's well-considered position on
this matter of the relationship between
self-sufficiency and friendship which
which seem to be at odds with each other
he's saying no they actually harmonize
quite well